let's jump to this next story we'll have
a good time here we got this from the
daily wire Vanity Fair published fashion
feature on Sam Brinton showcased
allegedly stolen dress I love this story
there's uh this uh not this one where is
it non-binary former Biden official Sam
Britain has been uh
released without bail the story is that
there's this woman who started Google
searching Sam Brinton after she found uh
that he was stealing luggage from the
from various airports she says that she
had had her luggage stolen and sure
enough he's wearing her clothes
incredible she is a designer I mean the
story is crazy take a look at this she's
a Asia Thompson Christina Pasha says
cultural appropriation is stunning and
brave as long as you are non-binary this
is the stolen dress this dude Sam
Brenton I don't think it's non-binary
all the style of Sam Brenton Vanity Fair
yeah all the style that he stole that's
so amazing that he decided he stole
luggage and then wore the clothing in a
photo shoot
like that
what are you doing
look man when you have corrupt people in
government they hire more corrupt people
and the corruption expands yeah and
we're getting to the point where it's
gone from corruption to degeneracy yes
Bingo exactly you know there you go I
just I just don't know how do you what
happens when you put mentally meant
there's something mentally not right I
don't know if it's a personality
disorder or a mental I I think this dude
is a kleptomaniac yep I think that he's
not non-binary I think his thing is
like he stole luggage and then wore it
in a magazine yep that's that's the
audacity it's like I I think he's a
kleptomanic he gets off on the rush
and then then showing it off like
keeping it like a souvenir exactly oh
like showing off his kill or something
yes exactly yeah
he was in a magazine or a fashion show
or something with this stolen dress like
that's showing it off that's going to
the highest Place
amazing look at me and it's allegedly
look some lady came on Twitter and said
these were these are my clothes that got
stolen yeah who made dress she said and
we know that he has been stealing
people's clothes and wearing it so it
just fits the ammo it really does that's
a that's a great job there uh bite
Administration hiring this guy it's
custom-made so you know she's
so ridiculous see I'm grateful for
stories like this because it brings me
back from the the brink of Despair I'm
like this is funny like you can't you
gotta enjoy the good times who's been
fired right yeah yeah he got fired he
got prosecuted too yeah yeah well that's
the story here from Fox News he was uh
released without bail
he faces theft charges in Nevada people
are telling this woman to press charges
he's he's flaunting he's wearing the
evidence
people like this ought to be stopped I
mean this is the type of guy that's
gonna keep doing it can we be mean to
him yeah
that's creepy that's cruel you can be
mean without being cruel like saying
he's a thief uh has no place in business
what about degenerate that's cruel once
you start insulting like name calling
what about the dinner it's not an insist
dudes little people's clothes from the
airport this that's not degeneracy right
that's weird I'm saying literal generous
generous I didn't say he was like a poo
poo face yeah exactly he's a degenerate
he is he is bringing degeneracy to our
culture he is degradating our culture
and Society he is breaking its laws and
uh and and what's flaunting this and
what's worse is he does it under the
guise of being non-binary which is I
guess trans adjacent I I don't know it's
body armor so yes so exactly it's body
armor so he's protected in the same way
that you can't criticize a child like
David this creeps out against guns this
dude's stolen dresses or body can't
criticize somebody who's on the spect
like it's a shield that they have you
can't criticize them for doing things I
have a huge list of nasty things I could
I could Ori about this fellow I mean I
use words for a living I could shred
this
this guy into Oblivion with my thoughts
and my words but I will not because I
don't think it ends the culture where I
think it inflames it so that's fair but
I I think these people should be laughed
into Oblivion I'll go down the mount
Wallace Line of things here I mean like
really this these people should be in no
positions of power and anyone that has
this type of degenerate Behavior should
not even be considered for any job ever
again these people are crazy stealing
stuff yeah he's a criminal criminal I
believe he's been laughing at people
mercilessly and that's how you get power
over them and then when they call you
like a bigot you say your words have no
power here and then they just don't know
what to do because their words are their
weapons they hiss they go yeah I don't
know what to do yeah then they get
pushed back by the force of will look
this guy then they indict Trump you just
right this is the problem is that one
side is constantly being like well you
know let's tolerate it the other side
saying we will burn it all down and that
means there is a a negative flow
politics only flows to the left it's the
way I've always described it if a
right-wing individual stands next to a
left-wing individual everyone says that
left wing guy's a right wing guy or the
left does the right won't call the left
wing or right wing but the left will
call the left Winger right wing right
it all Flows In One Direction the left
will show up with crowbar's baseball
bats and Molotov cocktails and the right
will say slow about their Democrats you
think that's because when we start
politics we start the and it becomes
that is the conservative Benchmark for
reality is our constitution now and and
it flows towards change which is the
left I think yeah because the
conservative part the conservatives are
saying we're going to hold our ground
here and the progressives are saying
we're going to drag you over here if
your entire mission is to just stay in
one place well then the person that's
trying to drag you if they take you even
an inch well then they're winning
you're not ever trying to take it back
the other direction the conservative
design the Overton window shifted so
much you could be a card-carrying
communist who's Pro Ukraine and whatever
but if you say
I think that you shouldn't be able to
kill babies after 30 weeks you're that
you're right wing right like that that's
how it only goes in One Direction yeah
and I mean with with the the physical
conflict too the the the the people on
the right save Matt Walsh are like well
hold on there let's not be mean then the
left puts pictures of kids being thrown
in wood chippers because someone filmed
them at the Lincoln Memorial yeah like
yo Josie smallett goes and fakes a hate
crime
the the feds show up for a garage Paul
rope at NASCAR and then conservatives
Libertarians Independents this faction
are just like well you know we don't
want to be mean though it's like you're
getting flogged over the head yeah over
and over and over again and the only
thing I'm saying is like maybe we should
be a little bit meaner to these people
and shame them for being bad well I
think what's what's fascinating about it
is like the left now I'll say it first
by the way yes and but the left hasn't
taken over the culture with sunshines
and rainbows like they've taken it over
by shaming into Oblivion anyone who
didn't buy their nonsense for the past
30 years and much longer I'm just basing
it off my own life so like yeah I think
that you know turnabout is fair play as
they say in the UK like you should be
able to deliver them a little bit of
their own medicine and I think that
they've demonstrated that's actually
what you kind of have to do even if it's
against like my better instincts and my
better morals like I still if I want to
not end up in a hell hole then I kind of
enforced into the Matt Walsh world view
of like I'm going to destroy your spirit
just as you've attempted to do struggle
sessions these are struggle sessions
that are happening I mean look at the
last time it happened Marxism 101 yeah
but my concern is that the goal of that
or Mouse sect is to destroy the what
would you say destroy your uh how Matt
Walsh said If You're Gonna destroy my
what is it morale or whatever yeah I
think that the goal of that is to
destroy everyone's morale so if you
strike back by trying to destroy their
morale you're just feeding the victory
for them no it's like it wants the
collapse of everything so that hell can
break loose here's how it works you work
for a company and one day the boss says
hey there's some controversy related to
wokeness then the other partner at the
business says well if we side with
conservatives
then the left will destroy our building
and and maybe kill some of our family
members if we side with the left the
conservatives will complain on the
internet let's start with the left on
this one that's the safe safe bet that
is pushing politics in One Direction
well that paired with ESG and you have
just a linear March towards the left the
thing is I'm I can't stop people from
being cowards and I'm not going to
become a villain to scare them into
following me scare who what are you
talking about these corporations that
are like well the right doesn't do
anything they just complain I'm not
going to create like some I'm not going
to threaten their lives we should do
that we said we should be a bit mean to
bad people you're saying that these
cowards and corporations that are afraid
of the left are but they're not afraid
of the right so that's the problem is
that that's why they're siding with the
left
of their conversation was we should be a
bit meaner to bad people I did not say
anyone should go and throw molotovs or
anything like that I said we shouldn't
do that antifa is bad for doing that and
that actually erodes their support
however it is an uphill battle but we do
need to tell the likes of Disney they're
scumbags when they do the pride family
racist trash and we need to then when we
see these people at conventions be like
you are human garbage and then not
associate with them and have them be
like why is this guy mad at me because
you are promoting racism in our country
and I will not be nice to you because
you're a bad person but not being nice
is different than telling someone
they're human garbage do not go to
events and tell people that they're
garbage that's going to cause mass chaos
do not do that I think the point is that
they want there has to be consequences
to the actions right and that's two
sayings there has to be a consequence
like they say they don't want they don't
want to um to provoke the left because
they'll blow your building up you know
but in this case you have to in that
situation when you see someone doing
this you have to give them a card you
have to push back if you don't push back
they're never going to see any any then
what you say to them when you see the
Disney executive is you say I believe
you're cowardice and callow Behavior
warrants Severance from my contracts and
my business I will make sure that
everyone I knows will avoid your
products and your bottom line will be
eviscerated by my PR campaign whatever
it would cost you
in marketing I will cost you 100 fold in
PR damage you said something like that I
think economic is the way to threat if
you're going to threaten corporations
it's economically because that's what
they're afraid of when you say the
left's gonna burn their building on
they're afraid of the economic loss it's
not that they don't care about the
building itself you generally you
misunderstood you're saying they're
crazy you need to take a lesson from the
Communists on this okay Ian you you
can't see out like you need to
understand the analog and not the
digital you hyper focus on one specific
thing and you misunderstand the bigger
picture and the bigger picture is when
you have a community meeting and the guy
shows up who's been dumping feces in the
river you don't go well hold on don't be
mean to him guys we need to understand
why he's polluting our water supply you
say you out out gone you're not welcome
here anymore we're cutting you off and
you know what we're turning the power
off to your building because you're
using that power to dump feces in the
river we need to just say ostracize bad
people they are not part of what we are
doing they are destroying it a guy shows
up and he's flinging feces at your
children and you go well don't be mean
to him right no no you could be amazing
that's a death sentence if someone is
attempting to kill your kids by
poisoning them with feces that's a death
sentence so what would you call it when
they're trying to kidnap kids and
sterilize them
I I mean well that we tolerate we got to
be nice
if they're kidnapping children it's a
felony I don't know what to tell you
that whether they sterilize when so when
they have adult performers perform for
children in Texas and the cops say don't
look at me I'm not gonna do anything
about it
and you're saying well don't be mean to
these people now Matt Walsh is right I
said Don't Be Cruel you should be mean
to those people what you should
embarrass and humiliate them but not
because how is that not cruel well I
mean sometimes the nicest thing you can
do for someone is to humiliate them
perhaps fine whatever my point is the
people who are committing clear crimes
and the cowardice and the police who
refuse to do anything those cops should
be shamed that's why I've been very much
like fine whatever about the police
because these cops I watch in Texas
they're like well we know there are
adult performers in that building with
children and we're not going to think
about it it's like what dude it's
already illegal I I love Ian's
perspective because it's clear that he's
like he's leaning in towards his better
nature I have attempted to do that my
entire life for the record Ian I am now
in Tim and Matt Walsh's Camp entirely I
think that you have to you you can't
just put your foot in the ground and
draw a line you actually have to go on
the offensive and I don't mean violently
or anything like that ever I mean you
have to be on the offensive in terms of
changing the culture letting them know
there is a line that you cannot cross
you have crossed it so now I have to
push you back and metaphorically pass
that line because you're too far you've
gone too far already and do what the
left does when they show up to your
coffee shop you say I'm sorry you can
leave they do it to cops all day every
day you know you can't come in here
we're not going to serve you and we're
like oh I never we wouldn't do it well
you know what maybe the parallel economy
is the way it's got to go because
they're weaponizing this against you
while you try and be tolerant and play
nice exactly so if they show up to your
gas station to your oil change shop or
whatever you know auto shop you say uh
what did you need you needed your brakes
not not for you no you can leave yeah
have a nice day and I think I think if
you do that it's it's sad but if you do
that and people start to realize the
trajectory on that we're on maybe then
they will realize look there is actually
a price to be paid for dividing this
country based on ideological lines and
if they don't want to go down that path
they also have a choice to make can we
leave the kids alone or not because if
they do I think you'll see a much you'll
see a return to the much more you know
Christian conservative type Mantra but
at this point they've gotten so deranged
that you're going to you're going to
force the what are you normally very
calm people into taking a much more
the geoli perspective and stance I I
believe in fighting fire with fire when
it comes to this I want to tell you a
little bit about some communists so in
the Communists over in Europe during the
um during the the second world war they
released a message to the American
Communist saying if any
um if any dissenter becomes particularly
annoying you need to label them a Nazi a
fascist or an anti-semite then fast
forward
1947 or wait no 47 37 47 I think yeah uh
Walt Disney has to go before the board
and he's goes before uh Congress and he
tells them about the Communist
infiltration of Hollywood and
um and like how this is really bad and
he goes in depth and the Communists are
like really mad at him and they're like
all right we're going to destroy you
from the inside out we're going to taint
your legacy we're gonna we're gonna
we're coming for you it's essentially
what they did and if you think about
today what Walt Disney's company looks
like it is infiltrated with Communists
and filth and disgusting stuff and if
you also think about tainting him they
went on to call him an anti-semi and
that kind of faded into history as truth
um but there's there's not there's
nothing really that you can find his
company actually made for propaganda
films against the Nazis
um so I believe in like this is their
their tactics is they gained Power by
calling everybody a fascist everybody a
Nazi everybody in anti-semite and
sometimes you got to use gotta use it
again 80 years for the conservatives to
figure out the game yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member or over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time